a recent valve sanctioned cs go
tournament with major qualifying
implications and big-name
teams like navi vertice pro and gambit
competing
was well a total disaster
from no anti-cheat to zero stream to lay
to a
swath of cheating allegations those same
teams were fed up
and have signed an open letter to valve
asking the developer to investigate the
entire
event
[Music]
alright guys do it all do everything you
already know i'm humbly going to ask you
to do
like the video subscribe to the channel
hit that notification bell so you never
miss new content and if you have a story
idea you want to see us cover here on
don't at me
send a tip to tips at thescore.com
running throughout the month of may the
epic league was a cs go tournament
hosted for regional cis teams like navi
vertice pro and gambit there's the swing
good for one
1v1 with simple simple on the jumper
spot means someone has to desperately
try to reload in the corner
tag down further simple can he finish
the job continuing to just toy with his
food
joey for the jump spot hobbits he can't
risk going for this bomb
and simple foster hobbits if you know
anything about cs go those names should
clue you into the fact that
this was a notable event with quality
competition
involved add in the fact that rmr points
were up for grabs and
yeah this tournament was more than just
target practice for the likes of simple
rmr or regional major ranking points are
what teams compete for
in these smaller regional tournaments in
order to qualify for valve sanctioned
majors which are cs go's most
prestigious tournaments
and each tournament win or let's say top
five placement
earns a team a certain amount of points
and it turns out that even tier one
tournaments with big name talent
involved
can be a [ __ ] show which is absolutely
what this was
organized by the russian esports
federation or resf
and epic esports events this tournament
had no third party anti-cheat
no stream delay on go tv and apparently
team coms were just never recorded and
if you're new to cs those things
are the staples of maintaining
competitive integrity
for basically any tournament whether
it's online or
honestly on land now the implication of
the no third party anti-cheat no
stream delay or no recorded team comms
is that it would have been incredibly
easy for someone to cheat
if they wanted to which is exactly what
14 out of the 16 teams who competed
accused this org akuma of doing in an
open letter
they wrote and signed to developer valve
which was published on june
3rd quote we want to share our feedback
on the cis rmr held by the resf
our mutual concern is a suspicion of
dishonest play from the akuma team and
players
based on the information we have we
suspect the akuma team and players
received live data from third parties on
external devices
in order to gain the unfair advantage of
seeing opponents position
on the maps at all times end quote now
let's back up a second i first got wind
that something weird was going on when
on may 29th simple tweeted out about the
lack of no
anti-cheat recorded comms no replays
or the lack of information regarding
fifth sixth place
matches for the tournament a few hours
later this statement from zort who plays
for
fours started making the rounds on
twitter and he reiterated what simple
said
no anti-cheat no stream delay and no
recorded comms
according to zord all anyone needed to
watch the games in real time and
therefore have the ability to stream
snipe other competitors
was the password to go tv which
apparently was the same one for the
server now
akuma the org accused of cheating went
on a bit of a run
throughout this tournament defeating the
likes of navi and virtus pro
they would eventually finish in third
losing to gambit in the upper bracket
finals
this would have been impressive were
they not facing widespread cheating
allegations from
pretty much every team involved then on
may
30th a reddit post started circulating
with a [ __ ] ton of clips
allegedly showing akuma cheating here's
some of those clips now
stored
foreign
now to be honest with you there's
nothing in those clips that explicitly
yells cheating to me and
i haven't watched cs go long enough to
pick up on the subtle micro movements
that could tip somebody off to the fact
that somebody else might be cheating but
again this tournament used
no anti-cheat outside of the valve
developed vac
which let's be honest is a joke and
apparently wasn't even enabled
for the tournament and akuma is being
accused of everything from using
radar hacks to aim locking software then
later that same day the resf released a
statement regarding the cheating
allegations against
akuma quote during the internal and
external investigations a large amount
of information was collected about the
actions of okuma
the work of gotv and the line
administration of the tournament
the analysis of this information did not
reveal any evidence of compromising the
administration of the tournament
and the work of gotv a review of akuma
players their hardware and software
revealed no signs of foul play we have
collected all the necessary information
to make a decision
notified valve and esic of the situation
and are ready
if necessary to conduct a retrial with
their participation
providing the full amount of information
we have collected
end quote they ended their statement by
saying the epic league
closely follows all valve related
guidelines which is
funny considering again they had no
third party anti-cheat
stream delay or recorded voice comms all
things that pretty much every other to
would have in place also apparently the
matchmaking was an absolute
[ __ ] show at first navi and entropic
mutually decided to cancel their match
at the last minute which
is unusual and to make things even more
weird then it seemed like they were
going to have to split
50 rmr points between the two teams
but then they did end up actually
playing that match that was cancelled
and
navi ended up winning two nothing on top
of that apparently the grand finals was
switched at the last minute from a best
of three to a best of five which is
really not what you want to see if
you're a team gearing up to compete
then on june 1st speculation continued
to circulate
that akuma was suspected of quote using
additional assistance
during the rmr event end quote
apparently all relevant information is
going to be collected and sent
off to the esports integrity coalition
or
esic for review esic is an independent
body
a watchdog of esports of sorts they
investigate analyze and pass down their
recommendations to tournament organizers
regarding
all sorts of alleged infractions within
esports
we've talked about them a bunch on this
show before and i reached out to them
for comment on this situation but
never heard back in time for publication
safe to say that the community was
buzzing about this controversy
throughout the week
navi's head coach joined hltv's
confirmed
podcast on june 2nd to talk about the
situation
and straight up said he believes akuma
100
cheated personally i think that they
were cheating like 400
okay yeah uh especially
sergis you know this guy the way how he
actually push some positions
uh we knew that he would push some
positions
and at the end he pushed him but
all the time it was when we were not
watching him now we still haven't heard
back from valve on this which is
honestly not surprising like my
co-worker dimitri said earlier when we
were talking about this story
valve could come out with a
comprehensive response
tomorrow or just never mention it
like ever okay back to the open letter
signed by 14 out of the 16 teams
i wonder who didn't sign it akuma
sorry got some caught in my throat there
the letter states that
while the resf found no violations
these teams don't quite believe them
because of the following reasons
quote teamspeak communications were
never recorded
teams repeatedly questioned this
decision and asked that all
communications be recorded but their
requests were dismissed
the resf explained this with the fact
that recording teamspeak communications
was not in valve's requirements however
we believe that recording teamspeak
communications has long been the norm
for every big tournament
not to mention the qualifiers for a
major there was no third party
anti-cheat which has long been an
industry standard and the additional
tool for any leading to
in some of the matches there was no go
tv delay
while in others there was a delay of up
to 30 seconds
from there the teams that signed the
letter laid out their expectations for
tournaments of this caliber in the
future
including recorded teamspeak comms and
third-party anti-cheat
and a delay of at least 30 seconds now i
honestly believe that if this had
happened at an fpl
level or even an mdl semi-pro level
nobody would have batted an eye the
reason why this is such a big deal is
that it's happening at the highest level
of counter-strike
with implications for the biggest
tournament of the year
on the line the idea is that this level
of quality or
rather lack thereof should never be
happening at a valve sanctioned event
whether they're valve mandated or not
industry standard guidelines should be
followed to a t
and the absence of something as simple
as a third-party anti-cheat
throws up red flags left and right this
is something that blade
highlighted in that episode of confirmed
that we played for you earlier
yeah there was no anti-cheat there was
no delay in goat on go to be
uh so it's it's like uh
they i think they tried to to be
not the best but the worst and of course
the whole little details in terms of how
they
uh operate uh specific matches like
admin
teamspeak and everything like this like
after blast and esl it's
a huge difference you feel it and you
see i think
how how is it possible now for the sake
of competitive integrity moving forward
it would make sense for valve to come
out with some sort of statement about
this situation
but then again valve and common sense
have
never really gone hand in hand so for
the time being
all we can do is sit back and see what
happens
these ones aren't scented usually i get
scented ones because i mean who
wants to smell that but whatever reason
these are not scented
poop bags and don't worry they're not
used i'm not like some sort of psycho
i don't think this would fit on my head
if i
that's about as close as i can get you
know
i don't know what you want from me